i want to start with the most important
thing which is nobody was great
uh you kicked so much ass uh i know it's
gonna be a big hit
but before we get into that uh i am a
huge fan of the sketch
matt foley motivational speaker yeah and
i just want people to realize that you
came up with this
and i sort of want to you know shine a
light on that and basically
i know you've probably talked about it a
million times but what was it like
getting to work with chris farley it was
the greatest joy
uh in show business um
seriously it was uh
it's a i'm writing my memoir right now
and it's amazing what a big part of it
of the story i devote to chris and
the short time that i worked with him uh
because he was just a beautiful spirit
and a beautiful
guy and and a joy and so funny
um and the fact that i got to write that
and the magic
quality of writing that scene which
really was uh
one of those things that you just feel
didn't even come from you
you know it just came out of the air and
uh
it was a wonderful experience my
daughter asked me what
the most fun is i've had doing what i do
and i said it was doing the sketch
motivational speaker with chris farley
at second city
eight times a week it was a great joy
i have to ask you as since you're
writing your memoir um
you have done your there's so many
things i could spend this interview
talking
about with you your resume and what
you've done in your career is so
diverse and wide-ranging did you keep
journals along the way or are you sort
of like being like
you know 1992 god damn it why didn't i
write down what i did that day
steve uh it is the latter yes
i don't remember a [ __ ] thing and i
literally had to
do what you just said i had to sit down
and write down where i was
what i was doing i had to interview my
old friends
and ask them what happened there i think
it was this what do you remember
some stuff i just literally put in my
book i
i just put um the interview answers
like for instance like the i wanted to
write about the ben stiller show because
i loved that show and
it was a big thing for me when i was on
it and
i couldn't remember so much
so i just interviewed judd and he gave
me all the
he he was great he did remember stuff
judd has a a crazy memory yeah so he was
great
um so people saved me but
yeah i it's it was a struggle to
remember i
i don't remember as much as i wish
jumping into why i get to talk to you uh
when did you decide you wanted to take
over liam neeson's action roles
well liam called me and said i really
hate show business i'm so sick of it but
they won't let me leave until someone
agrees to take over
and i said god damn it liam all right um
you know uh in the second season of salt
my brother-in-law sent me a screen grab
of an advertisement for better call saul
in china and i thought holy [ __ ] i know
they watched
the show in russia in italy and france
china too what could i make what movie
could i make that could play around the
world and i thought you know action
plays around the world and
i'm in pretty good shape and i could get
in better shape i haven't hurt my knees
or my back
so i could train if i had the gumption
um and i also had this experience in my
life where there was this break-in and
it left me with these feelings of
frustration and rage towards
this incident that happened and uh they
really stuck with me
for years and i thought i could build a
character out of that
i mean that's a guy who would go off a
person who felt those feelings
and uh i went around with that idea
my pre my um my manager mark provosero
said yeah that you could be an action
lead with that idea
and if you're willing to train and we
asked some writers and derek colstead
who wrote john wick
loved the basis of the character
and i started training and he started
writing and
kelly mccormick and david leach came
aboard and braden after good
and those are people who made hell or
high water
john wick deadpool
atomic blonde so they're an incredible
crew of people who
make action movies so
i was in the best you know in in the
hands of the best people in the business
and i just devoted myself to going to
the gym
three times a week for two to three
hours at a crack
and just thousands
of movements of the same over and over
of just getting your body to stretch and
learn punches and learn what looks good
on screen
and and just kind of get the basics
i have a feeling this is going to be a
big hit and the reviews are going to be
very strong
i'm curious uh have you been maintaining
staying in the gym
yeah cleaning this thing in case you get
to do a sequel
well it's not in case i get to do a
sequel it's because i
i grew to like feeling good
physically and feeling fit um and i know
how to
i know how to exercise now you know i
just didn't know
i'm i really recommend to anyone
don't just do the boring exercise that
you do
that that makes you frustrated or bored
or lazy or that makes you not want to do
it
go on youtube type in
something abs upper body
any [ __ ] thing and watch two or three
videos and pick some
exercises and do them just there's
thousands of ways you can exercise your
body
and you'll develop tone and you'll get
better energy through the day
and you know for me the gym was a boring
place
but training for this movie made it a
fun and interesting place
oh i watched your video of uh of you
training at your place
listen before i run out of time i am
such a huge fan of better call saul
and i am very curious um have you guys
started filming the final season
would you like tomorrow oh for real yeah
i fly out in the morning yeah oh my god
okay um
is brian cranston finally gonna direct
an episode
this i do not know um i've only got the
first two
so uh i hope
that that happens i've heard that rumor
but i have not
seen anything factual that it's going to
happen yet how
long ago did vince tell you has he told
you
ultimately where this is all going to go
or are you finding out script by script
i'm finding out script by script i'm
told that the wheels come off in season
six
and it explodes in a million directions
uh that sounds to me like there's a fair
amount of violence
but i don't know for a fact
we have a discussion where
my point of view is that
walter white became a angry
broken version of himself
and i wonder if it would be possible to
write
because i like the guy i wonder if it
would be possible to give
jimmy mcgill a better ending a better
place to end in
than he started in i don't know if
they're gonna
do that though one of the things that i
love
is all the black and white stuff at the
beginning and end
of seasons um could you sort of talk
about uh
uh that aspect of the show and how it's
so different than
what typically is out you know what i
mean like the ambitious nature
of the storytelling yeah um when you say
that
what i think about is i've often thought
there's no way we could do with the show
we've done
if breaking bad hadn't existed and not
simply because
saul was invented for breaking bad but
because
breaking bad trained
the audience to care about details
and to know that every little detail
will pay off and matter so because
they got everyone in the world
to see that that that could be
a story you're watching that if you
watch every little thing
it will matter one day then we got to do
better call saul which
is this quiet idiosyncratic
subtle quirky
show where things aren't running on
parallel tracks a lot
and you're like but you know you know
they're going to all come together and
they're all going to matter
to each other but you know that because
you watch breaking bad
and so we're very lucky to
to make this interesting show and it's
only because
breaking bad was so good that we get to
do better call saul
yeah listen man i i love better call
saul
i think that the show is just so
incredible in your work and it is
phenomenal i thank you so much for your
time today
and um seriously nobody kicked so much
ass you were fantastic
thank you buddy